the NHS Confederation represents the
Whole Health Care system in England
Wales and Northern Ireland and its chief
executive Matthew Taylor joins me now
good morning Matthew good morning how
serious is the risk to life being posed
by the strikes that we can see coming
ahead
well there are two elements that I think
are particularly concerning to us the
first is the rcnr excluding from
derogation derogation is the way in
which the trade unions agree that they
will cover certain
the key areas that are involved in the
protecting life and limb and the RCN
have said that some of those errors will
not be covered in that x-ray that
includes for example Emergency Services
and we're also concerned about the
speculation of the possibility of a
combination of Junior doctors and nurses
actions so both of these things would be
a significant
escalation and it's very difficult to
see how either of those things wouldn't
endanger patient safety and dignity
you're saying that you think that
specifically because of these tactics uh
there is a an elevated risk that people
will die
yes I think that that that the whole
point about escalating industrial action
is it becomes tougher tougher to handle
it's it's trying to send
a stronger message it's important to
recognize that that we understand the
anger of nurses we understand the anger
of of Junior doctors and their concerned
not just about pay but about conditions
of work
but in relation to both the disputes uh
in terms of Junior doctors travel we
called last week for acas to be involved
because there seems to be no basis to
the junior doctors and the government to
talk to each other BMA of agreed to that
we encourage the government now to call
in a class so at least talks can start
in relation to the RCN
um as you know the trade unions the NHS
trade unions work together as a group
through their NHS staff Council Unison
voted in favor of this deal we have to
hear from any other unions unite GMB and
others and we would
encourage the nurses to wait until we
have the collective view of the NHS
trade unions before deciding what to do
next
hope I think both on the government side
and possibly even amongst some uh people
within the RCN that the votes that we'll
uh we'll hear the results of this week
will change the situation and that in
practice what will
what will turn out is that irrespective
of the RCN ballot that actually uh the
money will will end up that they'll vote
to accept and that uh the money will end
up in people's pay packets and things
will settle down but I just want to
stick for a moment with this issue of
the uh abandonment of derogations
is there a sense in which
we are now in a very dangerous situation
in which
if you like the ethical boundaries of uh
the industrial relations conflict have
been broken in some way that the things
that everybody would accept
or previously accepted as a boundary
Beyond which you you do not pass has now
been erased
well certainly uh as I said Trevor when
we're talking about escalation when
we're talking about the derogations that
are being respected in the past uh being
excluded in this industrial action so
that it does affect for example
uh emergency services and when we're
talking about the possibility of
combined industrial action this does
take us into uh Uncharted Territory and
it means that the people that I
represent will have to spend a great
deal of time doing the detail planning
the detailed negotiation with trade
unions locally to try to ensure that we
can protect life and limb so so none of
this is welcome so however much we
sympathize with the case of the doctors
and the nurses and however much we
continue to press the government for a
proper Workforce plan something to be
arguing for for years and continues to
be delayed we do want to avoid this
industrial action because the other
thing I think I'd say from it is yes we
can focus on what happens on those days
of industrial action I was in hospital
last week the hospital was coping pretty
well in terms of emergency cover with
the junior doctors on strike but I spoke
to surgeons on the surgical award at the
Consultants there they were keeping
things going but they were aware that
every day more people were being added
to their lists because of canceled
outpatients appointments and canceled
operations and that harm that kind of
harm that comes from people having a
canceled operation a canceled
appointment it may not be immediately
life-threatening but it can still have a
huge impact on people
your members are essentially trying to
uh if if you like ameliorate the impact
of these actions and uh over time uh
things stack up and so on and so forth
is there a point Beyond which
essentially you can't do belt and braces
you can't bootstrap where actually the
service collapses
I don't think the service will collapse
I think that the NHS throughout its
history
you know as we approach its 70th
birthday you know I think we we cope
with anything that has thrown us us but
are we able to provide the level of
service that we want no we're not and as
the nurses and Junior doctors would
point out this is the case even when we
don't have strike action so whilst we've
seen some good figures last week we're
reducing the people who've had to wait
more than 18 months for operation to
almost zero there's been an improvement
in Diagnostics hitting some keep getting
coaches some key cancer treatment
targets you know we also heard last week
of what 10 of people waited more than 12
hours to be seen in emergency
departments so you know the NHS has been
run down it's been underfunded
particularly in relation to capital
investment in terms of Workforce so
we're not always able to provide the
care that we want but we are able to
make progress I think what's
heartbreaking for the people I represent
is that they're doing that work they're
making inroads they're seeing progress
we're starting to get closer to our
targets and then these days of
industrial action really knock us back
let's let's suppose that we actually at
some point do get a settlement let's say
in the next few months
how long do you think it will take the
NHS to recover from the disruption of
the last year
what was as I said we are starting to
make uh progress I think with a fair
wind
um if the industrial action wasn't
taking place we will continue to make
that progress and I think a critical
thing now Trevor is preparing for next
winter Europe as your you know viewers
will will recall we've had a really very
very tough winter we had a combination
of flu and covid and and
situations and parts of the Health
Service that none of us wanted to see
so I think we've got to make further
inroads into those people who've been
waiting a long time to be seen and we've
also got to do the preparation and and
have a better winter so that we are able
to continue to make progress I'm
confident about the NHS in the median
term if we get the resources if we get
that Workforce plan
but it's tough because every day travel
we have to meet high levels of demand
driven I think like by things like
population uh aging public health
challenges at the same time as making
inroads into that backlog and that is a
difficult job day in day out but it
becomes almost impossible when you're
dealing with industrial action as well
Matthew Taylor thank you very much for
your time this morning thank you